hey guys today I'm going to carry on
playing inside for you we left off by
dying and a beam of light so let's carry
on trying to find out why people are
being controlled by helmets shall we my
problem is I rush into things my panic
like so easy I swear I had some someone
what do I do making a noise okay right
oh my god this game is so ruthless
though like even if you're in the light
for all my gosh i was talking to you
even if you're in the light for a split
second that's it over go back oh ok
maybe you like but they are pretty sure
than the light then but yeah no I'm
trying to say ok let's jump hi hi
Oh God oh dear see that the snoring
aren't they can you hear that so they
can't be dead cuz they're snoring okay
we're doing okay we need to get to that
hatch right Oh God whoa it makes me like
tense up everything he looks a train how
do i oh god
how do I do this Oh God just get in just
getting okay I think we're safe so now
wrong way this way Oh am I supposed to
go down here yeah I think I am okay
let's grab hold of this guy who's
obviously underneath a big
something-or-other trying to escape and
this place is bloody massive as we've
been at this for a while I want to know
how he escaped because if he was just
like every other person being
mind-controlled he's got been pretty
willful you know it's gonna have a lot
of willpower to gather that was he under
mind control and then he got out of it
oh all the dogs Shh be quiet be quiet
uh they're gonna hear this did they hear
that are they up there I want to try and
find all the secrets as well because I
hate not finding secrets I want to find
all this little roundball things there
are any underwater oh no no I'm gonna
die gonna die get oh my god oh my god oh
my god ruthless they just snaps your
neck right off I'd much rather be shot
with those tranquilizing darts much
nicer come on dog bet you can't swim
though Kenya oh you can it's cool
because you can't see me hehe stupid ugh
they go come on this we can make it we
can make a big make it
too scared phone oh bloody hell okay
okay yeah you can we can do this when
you dance with get me how these are
formed by one it would help if I with a
lot stronger but I'm not saying yes this
ghost ghost ghost ghost by dogs don't
want you in my life there's a lie i do
want to dog in my life but not i don't
like that okay don't jump like don't
jump what did I just say I said don't
jump I wanted to get on the ladder
this
oh my gosh mm-hmm Susan balance
this is cool
d
I'm so excited for this let's go in the
submarine
sneaked past these guys
oh yeah oh it's the curious little
submarine I have ever seen look at that
it looks like him one of those little
minds in a aah crash bandicoot one thing
I think Thanks the crash bandicoot minds
looked a bit like this you know you had
to be careful of them in the underwater
levels and not not touch them booth
do I lose power when I do that because
it's gone like a boosie thing makes us
go ready fast for a second but then but
the hot lights kind of go on enough ah
that's beautiful
something in that skill in the pipe
system underneath the factory or
whatever whatever the thing is think so
this is red lights and stuff Oh some of
it been flooded
yeah definitely some of it it's been
flooded
perhaps these people whoever they are
are using like an abandoned factory to
do there whatever it is mind control
whatever yeah we definitely lose energy
tell me do that I think do you think we
can swim through the the crack aah
goodbye little submarine maybe I can
find a way to open the door so the
submarine can still come because i want
this submarine in my life I don't want
to leave it behind hey rats two rats
grow some things now you're right so
much better you here then can I go oh ok
so the waters down there what's up this
way and there's a button oh my god
oh my god let's go in the water that was
pretty dangerous brazuca we survived
those reflexes um are we supposed to do
something with those barrels now I don't
think so then we just go and have a look
in there in the room I really want to
understand the story so much I don't
know where abouts I am I think I'm about
halfway maybe i don't i don't know maybe
people said this was a short game but i
don't i don't think it is i think i
think this is a good legs hmm that's
strange we've just gone from from
underwater two overgrown with it's an
actual trees yeah its trees can I looks
like it's got a handle so I'm gonna blow
up is it oh yeah no I want to go up
there please take me up pick me up thing
I want to jump that way that way that
was cool this place is beautiful without
a doubt
everything's just so simple and that's
what makes it so pretty hasn't been they
haven't tried too hard Oh dig scary oh
my god terrifying oh you did it one
giant leap yes can we just jump down
horses yeah and then we can't get out
that way left server down oh my god what
the hell was that scared me what what
was that we're gonna go a look in should
we go look in
record it gone so what I mean this is
why I love underwater Clippers so many
weird creatures down here that we might
not even we might not even know what it
is because we don't live underwater did
you know that we don't live underwater
okay I can't find whatever that thing
was so what are we supposed to do can we
go over here I'm guessing if we use our
little power we can jump out of the
water probably I still want to find out
what the thing was already obviously
again there are those barrels I nearly
killed Miriam
button Frank impressive
what do we do
what
so here oh no that ain't gonna work
little submarine tada mm-hmm so cool
the shadow thing scared me is that
another person personal very long hair I
want your hair what is your secret why
I'm going talk to me please why isn't
this person dying Anna I think I'm
blinding here sorry she gonna follow us
whoa she swim so wait what you freakin
doing get away she's evil she wants to
kill us okay so I gonna keep her in my
sights so get away from my freaking
thing no no no Nana what are you no no
you stay away why would you why would
you kill me
if she's just an ocean swim so fast as
well I know you're I know what you're
trying to do that okay how can you swim
underwater like that and are they doing
experiments on people is that what
they're doing what am I supposed to do
with you little lady ah i think if we
knock into this thing it should lock her
out I think maybe she just wants a
French just doesn't realize that that
not everyone can breathe water in the
same way as her and she's just getting
overly excited because you know he is
he's a cute little chappy good I wonder
if we can see it through the crack
that'd be kind of creepy wouldn't it she
was still there
can that was so strange though I thought
this game was just about mind control I
didn't realize that there will be people
with powers what is this x-men in a
really creepy morbid style are we gonna
see her again oh we're outside we're not
inside we're outside OOP is that a rope
yeah it's one of those people there hey
are you okay come hard with this you'll
need to find the helmet can you hear
that strange noise it's like boom boom
that one I think we're getting closer to
it
yeah we are what is it I think that
needs some power maybe hi guys you okay
to do other noises cuz it's a little bit
unnerving just too tired 19 the canting
down this way over eighteen it is
counting down bloody for what no it's
not what's 19 oh if I go on here says 80
alright it's a little rope that we can't
get to train tracks and number two train
I'm guessing we're not strong enough not
strong enough to move any of this stuff
what's this oh oh wait there
ladder there's a lot of people on here
and there's the Hat this is like one
elaborate puzzle universe elaborate yeah
i donít funny we had our submarine do oh
wow I didn't think he'd actually be able
to climb it I'm impressed impressed with
a lot of things he does sees it he's a
very talented little climber and escape
her basically I guess he has to be or
else he's gonna be killed mold of ice
and dogs lasered by some little robot
alien things alien no robots this commie
aliens can it please don't tell me that
the spoiler is aliens don't tell me any
spoilers but I really hope the ending is
not about aliens because I was like the
cop out ending isn't it oh that's all it
is okay
huh made it Oh Lots they'll follow me so
I can do this wherever now so if you
guys help me ah amazing you guys can
help me and I can go well thanks guys
and then if I let you on to this ramp
this is brilliant I hope I get to keep
this heart forever it's like an actuary
I want to keep this up come on fellas
come towards me it's like they're just
attracted to the Hat now because I
didn't move them and they moved so is it
just like an attraction thing come on
guys follow me oh yeah you to you within
no slackin you at the end think of them
I love the way the old road and stuff
they're like and that's not their facial
expressions such as mine they don't
really have facial expressions
ok I'll do it straight away don't you
aight guys i won't make your hang around
ok thank you oh no I guess because I'm
going left there we going left maybe I
don't know not quite sure how this works
cuz obviously I was standing still them
and they were moving don't get the Hat
wet I'm guess or it might not work he
doesn't seem to be that bothered hey
guys don't worry I'm here to save you
and then control you with my pain you
get stuck here Wow oh my god of it I
feel exhausted genius I remember being
stuck on limbo puzzles for absolutely
days absolutely days come on
construction workers so maybe that's
what they're doing for them it's like a
job but instead of being told what to do
and being paid and stuff they just mind
control them to do it all I'm glad to
have you guys I need you
how much 18 eighteen nineteen nineteen
no 18 cuz in that's me too so one two
three is that for front seven eight a
thing so you got ten more i think
there's about eight I don't know it
you'll keep on running into each other
it's hot you'll just kind of marriage in
together oh come on and in one more to
our clan royalty okay that's stupid hold
me Cass hold me and they can they can
tell me okay oh it's like a little ride
you're welcome oh come on oh yes hi
welcome to our clan we are cold the
hotheads hotheads hardheads hard heads
I should never try oh we only need for
more money for more let me find out what
the crazy banging is all about we only
got four this is not taking a song as if
those I thought this was gonna take me
forever because it looks so complicated
oh yes we're pushing these guys are we
pulling they're like hey I wouldn't i
wanna have bad be careful don't die
okay um if they're still alive then you
guys a series on them being dead could
perhaps be true because I don't see how
they could have survived that fall thank
you okay see but that's one and that
one's dead what is this oh is it because
oh it's because there's only three in
that cage so we still need one more and
I guess this one still counts even
though they're dead this is morbid I
don't like
don't feel about this he's only a little
boy oh sorry I feel awful let's see if
they're still alive because if they're
not the are dead like the one we just
pushed down then perhaps these guys are
alive which means there's still hope for
them yet they can still escape as well
but also it means that we just killed
some people we just killed some people
oh my god no we didn't but we just we
just saw a dead one this doesn't make
any sense or any of you guys piecing
this together better than I am I mean
those of you who don't know the ending
yet so I'm trying my hardest and I'm
finding it really difficult but I've
enjoyed the game all the same I'm
exactly the same when I watch films I
just try and guess the ending I should
just enjoy it and guess the ending well
I'm sorry dead one and then yeah just
get to the ending later okay here we go
then I'm gonna follow me why don't you
follow me guys come on I can't do this
without you push me okay this is like
world war or something these grenades oh
Jesus
make sure we're undercover god okay what
is that I don't understand
that was close oh no we're gonna die
blown to bits mama mama mama mama my god
she just made it it makes me feel so
tense and anxious I don't know what I'm
day
I can't even talk to concentrate how was
the supposed to do that
Lynette really sorry guys but I'm gonna
have to leave it there because i'm a bit
stopped but gives us a thumbs up if you
definitely want to see more of inside
hopefully i think we might be nearing
the end I'm so intrigued to find out
what this is about because I've had so
many theories you've heard them all I
want to hear your theories in the
comments below but again please no
spoilers please no spoilers have a good
day or evening by what oh no I don't
know what oh no I know it's dear don't
judge me boom go this way good yes I
have no idea why they've got it out for
us so badly you didn't do something um
he's obviously